on the last day of passover over the
weekend
um another white supremacist opened fire
at a synagogue and this was exactly six
months after the pittsburgh
synagogue shooting this time it was at
chabad of poway
in poway california maybe it's
pronounced poe
the shooter was a nineteen-year-old
white supremacist
killed one woman injured three other
people including the rabbi
at the synagogue the shooter not super
surprisingly had an ar
style rifle on him when he was arrested
and yeah i mean importantly the shooter
was arrested not killed
a 60 year old woman was killed lori
gilbert k
who had jumped in the way of the rabbi
to protect
the rabbi from the shooter the rabbi
ended up
getting shot in the hand i believe had
surgery and is okay
but the woman was the one person killed
there was an off-duty border patrol
officer
in the synagogue just as a congregant
who opened fire in response to the
shooter
and actually hit the shooter's car but
the shooter was able to leave
at the time uninjured and eventually the
shooter was captured two miles away from
the synagogue and
every detail that we've learned about
this shooter
is sadly completely unsurprising the
shooter had written
an anti-semitic and racist letter which
was
posted on the internet message board
4chan the shooter
blamed jews for perpetuating a genocide
against the european race of course
european race is white nationalist white
supremacist code for
white people a common trope of the white
supremacist
movement in 2019 the shooter said that
hitler
as well as other previous white
supremacist shooters including the one
from the pittsburgh synagogue were
inspirations to him
and this is once again the type of
extremism that has been
catalyzed and coalesced and emboldened
by donald trump now
i'm not blaming donald trump for the
specific shooting and
if you're going to just write to me
saying david why are you blaming trump
just save your breath or your typing i
don't know whatever just don't do it
because i'm not blaming trump what i'm
telling you once again
is that anti-semitic incidents went up
in 2017
they went up in 2018 anti-semitic online
hate
is up as tracked by the center on
extremism
anecdotally uh anti-semitic comments
to me are way up not that that tells us
anything about the broader numbers it's
just an anecdote
trump personally being an anti-semite
who knows who cares
uh you know his son-in-law is jewish
it's doubtful that trump is sort of
consciously openly anti-semitic trump
didn't create
anti-semites but trump has been
signaling to these anti-semites and
white supremacists
as they have straight up told me on the
show i mean they've said it to me when
i've interviewed them
they see trump as the closest thing to
what they would like in a president the
signaling on
hispanic people on the [ __ ] countries
all of that stuff
and so the rhetoric rises the
anti-semites
who already exist are emboldened and the
proof is in the numbers that we are
seeing
and sadly the attacks on media by trump
also make it a lot tougher to fight
anti-semitism
because the way it works is when media
reports hey anti-semitism is way up
people who are not themselves
anti-semitic but have fallen for trump's
fake news the news is lying stuff they
just don't believe the reports about
anti-semitism they call them just
another uh example of the attempt to
attack donald trump
when will trump actually say we do have
a problem
with anti-semitism and white
supremacists in this country because
we've now have we now have the poway
synagogue white supremacist
the tree of life synagogue white
supremacist the oak creek sikh temple
white supremacists we've had instances
in canada we also have the new zealand
christchurch
shooting white supremacists who they
don't exist because of donald trump
donald trump didn't make them white
supremacists white but donald trump
didn't make them
white nationalists or anti-semites but
they're emboldened
they're taking action they've been
coalesced why is it so difficult
for donald trump just to say we have a
problem with white supremacy and
anti-semitism in this country
and we're committed to dealing with it i
think there's a real question there i'm
not asking it rhetorically i actually
want to know why won't donald trump say
it
the easy answer is because he's
anti-semitic i think the truth is far
more complicated than that i think
that's
too simplistic of an explanation but i'd
love to hear from you what you think is
going on there